GOING ON BECAUSE THEY CAN’T
POLICE IT?
>> John: REPUBLICANS SOUNDING
THE ALARM ON CLAIMS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND OTHER ABUSE OF
MIGRANT CHILDREN IN SAN
ANTONIO, TEXAS.
MORE THAN 172,000 MIGRANTS
ENCOUNTERED IN MARCH.
THAT IS A 20-YEAR HIGH.
IT INCLUDES NEARLY 19,000
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
THAT IS THE HIGHEST MONTHLY
NUMBER ON RECORD.
JOINING US NOW IS THE FIRST
OFFICIAL TO SOUND THE ALARM ON
ABUSE AT THAT FACILITY IN SAN
ANTONIO, TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT.
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU AGAIN TODAY.
YOU HAD ASKED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR ACCESS TO THAT
FACILITY.
THE FREEMAN COLISEUM AND YOU
WANTED TO KNOW WHAT WAS GOING
ON INSIDE.
WHAT HAVE YOU HEARD BACK FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO FAR?
>> I WILL TELL YOU ABOUT THAT
BUT FIRST LET ME MENTION THIS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO CAME ACROSS THE
BORDER JUST LAST MONTH.
IF YOU TRANSLATE THAT INTO A
12-MONTH PERIOD IT WOULD PRETTY
MUCH BE THE LARGEST CITY IN
TEXAS OF ALL THESE PEOPLE
COMING IN AND SHOWS THE HIGH
VOLUME OF THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER AND
WHAT IT CAN DO TO THE
POPULATION BASE IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
GOING SPECIFICALLY TO THE
FREEMAN CENTER IN SAN ANTONIO,
THERE WERE COMPLAINTS THAT WERE
FILED WITH STATE AGENCIES THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
COMMISSION AND CHILD PROTECTIVE
SERVICES AND THEY ARTICULATED
SPECIFIC ALLEGATIONS ABOUT
SEXUAL ASSAULT ON MINORS AT
THIS FREEMAN CENTER.
WE’VE BEEN ABLE TO TRY TO GET
IN.
I GOT IN WITH TWO TEXAS RANGERS.
THEY ARE TOW ELITE
INVESTIGATIVE FORCE IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS.
CHILD PROTECTIVE SERVICES AND
OTHER AGENCIES ARE NOT BEING
ALLOWED INTO THIS FACILITY.
I GOT TO TELL YOU LOOKING AT
THE FACILITY FROM THE INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE THERE WAS ONE THING
APPARENT TO ME.
THERE WERE ABSOLUTELY NO
SECURITY, NO GUARDS, NO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
NO ONE WHO WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PREVENTING SOMETHING LIKE
THIS FROM HAPPENING.
THERE WERE MASSIVELY
OVERCROWDED FACILITIES.
THERE WERE SO MANY PEOPLE IN
THERE ONE OF THE COMPLAINTS IS
THAT THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
ADULTS WHO ARE THERE TO
SUPERVISE THE CHILDREN BECAUSE
THE CHILDREN FAR OUTNUMBER THE
SUPERVISEORS AND AS A RESULT
THEY CAN GIVE RISE TO
ALLEGATIONS SUCH AS WHAT WE’VE
SEEN WITH REGARD TO SEXUAL
ASSAULT OF A MINOR IN ADDITION
TO THE OTHER ALLEGATIONS THAT
INCLUDE EXPOSING OTHER MINORS
TO THE SPREAD OF COVID-19.
THE NUMBERS THAT WERE PROVIDED
TO ME BY THE STAFF AT THE
LOCATION WERE ROUGHLY ABOUT 15%
OF THESE YOUNG CHILDREN HAVE
COVID WITH CHALLENGES ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO CONTAIN THE
SPREAD OF THAT COVID BECAUSE
THESE CHILDREN WILL EXPOSE
THEMSELVES TO OTHER CHILDREN AS
WELL AS ADULTS IN THE LOCATION
AND THOSE ADULTS COULD TAKE
THAT COVID AND SPREAD IT INTO
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
>> John: CLEARLY THERE ARE A
LOT OF CONCERNS HERE.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT POPULATIONS
AS WELL WE’RE EXPECTING TO HAVE
THE NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS CROSS THE BORDER OVER
THE NEXT 12 MONTHS THAT WOULD
EQUAL THE POPULATION OF THE
CITY OF FORT LAUDERDALE AND NOW
HEARING TERRIBLE STORIES, JASON
JONES WHO USED TO BE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY
TALKED ABOUT AN 8-YEAR-OLD BOY
FOUND DEAD OUT IN THE DESERT
BECAUSE OF CONDITIONS THERE AND
TEXAS RANCHER WHITT JONES ON HE
AND HIS NEIGHBORS FINDING DEAD
MIGRANTS ON THEIR PROPERTIES.
LISTEN HERE.
>> BASED ON WHERE YOU ARE
GEOGRAPHICALLY LOCATED AND HOW
PEOPLE TRAVEL AND WHERE YOU ARE
AS TO WHERE THE BODIES ARE
FOUND.
BUT WE FIND MORE TWO TO THREE.
THAT’S STILL ENOUGH.
NEIGHBOR OF MINE HAS BEEN
FINDING CLOSE TO 10 A YEAR FOR
THE LAST 10 YEARS.
THERE IS A SENSE OF FEAR THAT
EXISTS DOWN HERE ALL THE TIME.
IT IS A TERRIBLE SITUATION.
>> John: THERE ARE PLENTY OF
JANE AND JOHN DOES FOUND
DECEASED OUT THERE IN THE
DESERT.  WE SEE THESE OTHER
PICTURES LIKE THE 3 AND
5-YEAR-OLD GIRLS WHO WERE
DROPPED OVER THE BORDER FENCE,
THAT 11-YEAR-OLD BOY THE OTHER
DAY ABANDONED BY THE GROUP HE
WAS TRAVELING WITH, AND YOU
WONDER WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE ON
THE LEFT THAT WE HEARD SO MUCH
DURING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
TO SIMILAR SITUATIONS?
>> YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT AND
THAT’S WHAT PEOPLE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND.
THESE HORRIFIC IMAGES AND
TRAGIC DEATHS AS WELL AS
ASSAULTS THAT WE’RE SEEING NOW
WOULD NOT BE HAPPENING IF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAD NOT
OPENED UP THE BORDER AND BEEN
COMPLETELY UNPREPARED FOR THE
MASSIVE INFLUX OF THE YOUNG
MIGRANT CHILDREN THAT THEY ARE
ENTICING TO COME ACROSS THE
BORDER.
THOSE DEATHS THAT YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT, THE BODIES THAT
WERE FOUND, THAT IS ONLY GOING
TO INCREASE AS THE SUMMER
MONTHS GET VERY HOT.
WE SEE THE DEATHS OF THE
MIGRANTS COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER INCREASE IN JULY AND
AUGUST WHEN TYPICALLY THE
TEMPERATURES DOWN THERE CAN BE
100 OR ABOVE 100 DEGREES.
THE TEMPERATURES ARE MILD RIGHT
NOW.
THE TERRAIN AS WELL AS THE
TEMPERATURE WILL BE FAR WORSE
IN THE COMING MONTHS AND WE
BELIEVE UNFORTUNATELY THE
DEATHS WILL INCREASE IN THE
COMING MONTHS.
THIS EXPOSES EXACTLY WHAT THE
CARTELS’ APPROACH IS.
THEY MAKE MONEY OFF GETTING
THESE CHILDREN TO COME ACROSS
THE BORDER.
ALL THE CARTELS WANT IS TO GET
MONEY BY DELIVERING THESE
CHILDREN ACROSS THE BORDER.
AFTER THAT THEY COULD CARE LESS
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM.
WE HAD THIS STORY ABOUT THE
CARTELS THROWING A YOUNG CHILD
A 6-MONTH-OLD CHILD INTO THE
RIO GRANDE RIVER THAT’S WHAT
THEY THINK ABOUT IT.
THEY DROPPED THE KIDS ACROSS
THE FENCE.
THESE ARE VERY DANGEROUS PEOPLE
WHO COULD CARE LESS ABOUT LIFE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO PROFIT OFF
THEM.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION NEEDS
TO CRACK DOWN ON THE CARTELS,
SECURE THE BORDER EXACTLY THE
WAY IT WAS DONE BEFORE WITH THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO PROTOCOL AND
MAKE SURE THAT THINGS LIKE
THESE TRAGEDIES DON’T OCCUR
AGAIN.
>> John: THANK GOODNESS THERE
WAS A TEXAS PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICER CLOSE BY WHEN THE
6-MONTH-OLD WAS THROWN INTO THE
RIO GROUND AND WENT OUT AND
SAVED HIM HIMSELF.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US TODAY.
WE’LL STAY IN TOUCH WITH YOU